[Musique]
j'ai envie de vous raconter une histoire
une histoire d'une petite fille une
petite fille qui est née dans les
ardennes belges dans les années 1980
cette petite fille elle a un rêve gagner
roland garros facile sauf que pour
gagner roland-garros il faut une
raquette de tennis et avec une balle
c'est mieux et donc à 9 ans elle prend
son premier court de tennis et tout de
suite elle accroche et du coup ben jour
après jour elles se rapprochent petit à
petit son rêve elle a 11 ans elles
rentrent de l'école et elle demande à
ses parents est ce que vous seriez
d'accord si je pars dans une école de
tennis parce que j'ai vraiment envie de
gagner roland-garros alors je suis pas
spécialement doué mais j'ai quand même
envie de repousser mes limites
ses parents à sa plus grande surprise
bas accepte et donc la voilà à 11 ans
dans une école de tennis
alors elle s'entraîne dur c'est tous les
jours elle tape dans cette petite balle
jaune
elle se rapproche doucement mais
sûrement de son rêve alors je sais pas
si vous savez mais l'enfance dans
sportif s'est fait beaucoup de
sacrifices
alors pour elle ça ressemble pas à des
sacrifices parce que de toute évidence
elle est faite pour jouer au tennis mais
à titre d'exemple c'est on ne part pas
en voyage scolaire avec l'école parce
qu'il faut rester en belgique
s'entraîner et participer à des tournois
mais aussi pas de soirée avec les
copines on reste et on s'endort tôt
hiver comme été qu'il pleuve ou qu'il
neige
on va courir le matin avant l'école avec
le coach derrière qui klaxonnent
voilà en topo de l'enfance d'un joueur
de tennis
cette jeune fille devient tout doucement
une adolescente et elle se dit j'ai
quand même envie en tout cas le temps
d'une soirée de me connecter à une
adolescence normale et donc elle accepte
l'invitation à deux copines pour une
soirée et donc la voilà en route pour sa
première sortie entre copines fêtes de
villages du coin
donc plutôt que d'enfiler les baskets et
du training belle enfile une tenue un
peu plus sympa la voilà en route
sauf que sur le chemin une voiture les
percute
elle se réveille à l'hôpital
là elle ressent plus ses jambes et elle
se rend bien compte que son rêve va être
difficile à atteindre
l'histoire de cette petite fille c'est
simplement la mienne quand je me suis
réveillé jour-là à l'hôpital je
ressentais plus mes jambes j'avais
terriblement peur et mon rêve c'était
complètement volé et pour la première
fois de ma vie mais je devais vivre son
rêve c'était compliqué pour moi mais
j'ai quand même un caractère ardennais
et donc du coup je me dis bah c'est bien
mais ok je gagnerai pas roland garros ça
j'en ai bien conscience
mais par contre j'ai clairement pas
atteint mon meilleur niveau et donc
après des mois de rééducation je
retourne sur un terrain de tennis
toujours avec cette même volonté j'ai 17
ans je me débrouille je trouve une
bourse et je pars aux états unis pour
défendre les couleurs d'une université
américaine
là bas on s'entraîne sur du béton et mon
corps radicalement après une grosse
année me lâche
j'ai vraiment terriblement mal et donc
après des litres et des litres de larmes
je prends la sage décision de rentrer en
belgique
j'avais sans doute besoin à l'époque
d'être prise au sérieux et donc je
m'inscris à la prestigieuse solvay
cool et la très vite je me rends compte
que je suis pas du tout à la bonne place
je me retrouve en quelques semaines des
courts de tennis américain à l'ulb a
essayé de m'intéresser à des choses qui
en fait ne m'intéressait pas du tout
mais bon toujours le caractère ardennais
qui revient donc je m'obstine un an
je m'obstine deux ans je m'obstine trois
ans je suis en 3e année en matin je
marche sur ce campus je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie c'était au mois de novembre
et l'ag une petite voix qui me parlait
qui me dit écoute aghet c'est simple
soit tu restes et huth et 1 soit tu pars
et peut-être tu survis donc je décide
donc d'abandonner solvay et pour la
première fois de ma vie là je me
retrouve clairement confrontée au vide
mais pire que ça je me retrouve
confronté à moi man et là pour le coup
c'est pas tous les jours très agréable
et s'ensuit une longue longue longue
longue descente aux enfers où je leur
faire face à plein de défi personnel
à l'époque j'ai un petit copain qui en
jour me dit écoute agathe c'est bien
mais le canapé le lit le lit le canapé
j'ai une proposition à te faire que
penses-tu dimanche d'aller boire le thé
chez ma tante
ou alors je vous dis pas l'excitation en
moi j'y vais me voilà dimanche après
midi à boire le thé et manger la tarte
chez la tante de mon ex petit copain
et là je suis attiré par quelque chose
sur la table de sa cuisine se trouve un
bloc de terre alors à l'époque j'ai
aucune idée de ce que c'est l'argile
mais je suis attirée elle me propose de
mettre les mains dedans et je met
littéralement les mains dans ce bloc de
terre la sensation je la vis encore ce
soir intérieurement j'ai du mal à
l'exprimer mais il se passe quelque
chose c'est comme une petite lumière qui
sera lui mme dans un tunnel en espèces
de déclic
la vie continue je suis toujours autant
paumé les mois passent les années
passent je sais toujours pas où je vais
mais j'ai ressenti ce truc j'ai la
chance de faire la rencontre d'une coach
sur mon chemin qui m'accompagne me guide
me montrant chemin au bout de mon tout
n'est qu'au bout de mon tunnel je décide
moi aussi de me former à
l'accompagnement individuel
alors aujourd'hui je travaille l'argile
pour ensuite coulé ma sculpture en
bronze et j'accompagne tout un chacun
sur son chemin de vie je vis à mon sens
de deux passions inestimable à mes yeux
alors pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça
de mon parcours
j'en ai tiré quelques idées ses idées
elles ne correspondent en aucun cas à
une vérité elles correspondent
simplement à ma vérité choisir de vivre
dans un espace étroit au milieu de ses
habitudes peut mener à une forme de
rigidité psychique bien plus douloureuse
que la souffrance à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés en cas de revers de médaille
car l'une en ferme l'autre libère sur
mon chemin j'ai découvert que les
opportunités déteste les circuits fermés
les opportunités déteste les routines
elle déteste les habitudes
j'ai aussi découvert qu'on nous en
sortir de sa zone de confort souvent une
petite voix nous parle
cette petite voix elle nous indique le
chemin à suivre le chemin vers nos rêves
vernon passion mon idée floue de
l'époque les mains dans la terre est
devenue ce jour une évidence sculpté
transmettre un message
et quand on ressent cette évidence on
ressent une profonde liberté on peut
trouver ce qu'on aime dans la vie en
choisissant de suivre des voies moins
conventionnel dans certains cas la
normalité clairement sa ans ferme
j'ai récemment découvert en bouquins et
dans ce bouquin il ya une citation qui
m'a énormément interpellé cette citation
lé de rosa luxembourg et elle dit ceci
ce qui ne bouge pas ne se rendent pas
compte de leurs chaînes et ça m'amène à
ma deuxième et dernière idée pour ce
soir certains échecs dans nos vies sont
inévitables on ne peut pas passer une
vie sans échoué sans échoué quelque part
à moins de vouloir tout contrôler ce
qu'on dit ce qu on fait comment on
s'habille qui on côtoie où on va vivre
où on part en vacances mais dans ce cas
là on passe à côté de soi mais pire on
passe à côté de l'autre
donc au final
ce qui est important c'est pas l'échec
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'on va
faire de cet échec
je ne suis évidemment pas occupé à vous
dire que les échecs ont été des périodes
agréable de ma vie j'étais terrorisée
j'étais dans un tunnel sombre et lugubre
et je n'avais aucune idée de la longueur
du tunnel dans lequel j'étais ni la foi
dans un hypothétique effet end mais
aujourd'hui quand je regarde dans mon
rétroviseur je me dis que ces épreuves
finalement elles m'ont permis de
construire ma sécurité intérieure
j'avais touché le fond et ce fonds est
devenu la base solide de toute mon
existence
alors oui parfois on prend des détours
oui parfois la vie nous donne de gros
coup dur sur la tête on s'immobilise on
est bloqué la question est
qu'allons nous faire de la prochaine
contrainte qui se mettra sur notre route
je voudrais clôturé cette soirée en nous
rappelant à tous que par le simple fait
d'exister nous influençons tous les
autres par le miracle qu'est la vie nous
touchons tous les autres nous n'avons
pas besoin de magie pour transformer le
monde
or le monde a besoin d'être transformés
de par les contraintes et les détours
que nous prendrons je nous invite à
devenir la plus belle part de nous mêmes
et à tous ceux qui parmi nous ce soir
traverse un désert intérieur traversant
long tunnel sombre et lugubre
vous n'êtes évidemment pas occupé à
faire le tour du monde en sac à dos mais
vous êtes occupés à faire le plus
merveilleux et périodes et voyage la
découverte de vous même et avec cette
découverte
la connexion à votre essentiel et avec
cette connexion la merveilleuse
connexion à l'autre alors du plus
profond de mon coeur est avec ma plus
belle sincérité je vous souhaite à tous
de merveilleux détour merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]